i
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les adolescents ont une
vraie carence de sommeil
un tiers d'entre eux manque
véritablement de sommeil le manque de
sommeil à l'adolescence occasionne des
difficultés scolaires des troubles de
l'humeur des troupes delà de la
concentration des troubles de
l'attention
[Musique]
idéalement un adolescent doit dormir 9
heures par nuit
mais c'est une moyenne qu'on peut
calculer sur la semaine en sachant
évidemment qu'il ya des petits dormeurs
qui peuvent se contenter de sept heures
par nuit et les certains adolescents qui
ont besoin de 10 heures par nuit
[Musique]
l'adolescent se couche plus tard parce
qu'il y a des raisons biologiques
dès la puberté sur le plan biologique il
y à des modifications qui font que
l'endormissement est plus tardif mais il
y a également des facteurs
environnementaux qui favorise la
difficultés d'endormissement chez
l'adolescent aujourd'hui et notamment l'
usage des écrans des stimulation
lumineuse du téléphone des
sollicitations des appels qui vont faire
que l'adolescent va résister au sommeil
il y a aussi des raisons psychologiques
qui font que l'adolescent aime bien et
tranquille le soir au moment où tout le
monde dort l'huile à la paix il est
tranquille il à l'abri ils aiment vivre
la nuit
et ça c'est vrai dans toutes les
cultures
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en france les adultes se couche très
tard et donc évidemment la famille
globalement se couche plus tard
et puis les adolescents sont beaucoup
moins d'activité physique l'après midi
donc ça a dû s'en soucie de démarrer
plus tard mais il serait bien aussi que
les français puissent se coucher
globalement plus tôt et puis savoir plus
d'activité physique